now you can get started alright so well
everyone my name is Chris I'm coming you
to this made up so most of you probably
haven't seen me before or I've seen me
around haven't really talked to me and
so I'm currently studying computer
science at oh you and I kind of you know
notice a general theme that for free
code camp and you know just around here
in general a lot of people then seem to
finish or either in finish computer
science in school or are coming from a
different field so I just wanted to give
kind of how I got started web dev
studying computer science in college so
just so you know where I'm coming from
I'll just go a little bit over kind of
my college history here kind of what I
did before I started coming to the
meetups so I was born and raised in
Canada the land of Canadian Geese and
nice maple syrup stuff like that
and after I finished high school in 2012
I moved here to Oklahoma to live with my
mom and I thought it'd be nice to attend
college in the States so since we live
really close to Edmond I decide to
attend UC oh and I started studying
Electrical Engineering there
and I did that for my first two
semesters and that was when I had my
first programming and computer science
experience at their engineering
computing class which was a required
class for all the engineering
disciplines and they taught that class
in C and so after my two first two
semesters I decided I wanted to do
something more related to computers so I
switched to our transfer to UC Oro U
which is where I am now and studying
Computer Engineering and here the
computer engineering curriculum is
basically the same as computer science
for the first two years or so so I went
through all of their other Java courses
and I studied abroad for a year in 2015
and I came back last year September of
last year and that's when I decided I
didn't want to really want to work with
hardware I wanted to focus more on
computer science and so now I'm fully a
computer science major
though I'll probably stick with this one
don't know yet fingers crossed so let's
go into how I got started in web dev so
I didn't learn any you know HTML CSS
JavaScript in school so my first
experience is actually an internship I
got the internship through a personal
connection through my mom and it was an
internship at a company which is
somewhat notorious around here
apparently that no one likes alamode and
if you don't know what alamode or what
they do they sell software for real
estate agents appraisers mortgage
brokers and they one of their products
is basically custom websites for these
agents and brokers hosted on their
custom CMS system and so my job as a
intern was their system was running on a
legacy flash system you know he had all
these fancy animations you could add
sound effects things like that and so
they were trying to read just you know
revamp that and use bootstrap so what
they had in the past was basically this
kind of might be a little bit hard to
see but so basically rich text editor
right you could put in text lists tables
images things like that and it would you
know compile it into HTML and you know
that works great for you know simple
text like that and just gets injected
into this page that looks like that you
know your top bar is all sidebars all
loaded in with flash you could put in
you know sound effects when you hover
over each button makes like a laser gun
sound like a it's really bad but anyway
so with simple content like that lists
and paragraphs that is pretty easy for
to generate but once you start adding in
you know old sorry
well sistar adding in styling to the
text like no bolding coloring different
layouts right you start getting you know
stuff like that you know weird font tags
everywhere empty strong tags and spans
and so if you've ever had the misfortune
of working with this kind of HTML I'm
sorry but basically they had all of
their default content pages were you
know either laid out with tables or it
was laid out or had lots of you know
font tags laid out everywhere and so
it's basically my job to turn code that
looks like that into you know just like
that right the bootstrap framework it
already Styles all of your default
components right so you don't need
anything there and so if you have this
it looks consistent on all the sites and
it'll be updated by any you know
site-wide things that the customer may
choose so I was think about demoing some
of the things I built so I worked on
this for about two two weeks I
transferred all of their content pages
into clean HTML before I started
building some actual template pages that
customers could buy I was going to demo
them but maybe we'll say that for the
end if we have time
so how did learning computer science in
school you know actually help me in this
internship i well i okay well it didn't
really help directly it so let me
explain right so at oh you if you if
you've taken classes oh you you'll
you'll find out really quickly that oh
you is mostly a java school right most
of their for yeah most of their classes
you know for the better part of your
degree you'll be working with java for
all of your classes now you have maybe a
few classes here there that uses
something else but for the most part is
java and i think you know that while job
is a great language you know it's got a
robust API it's got you know good type
safety stuff like that the students
can't get locked into thinking rather
than thinking how can i write this in
code it becomes how can i write this in
java and so it get kind of locked into
that mentality of how to write software
in code and so some of the things that I
wish that I knew before when I was at
the internship May and just you know in
general that they didn't teach this is
by no means an exhaustive list but
essentially they I would have wished
that they taught me how to code better
right so just general learning different
languages right I was you know using
Java basically the whole time I was
there except for one class and good
programming practices so things like how
to write clean code how to put in proper
comments there was if you followed the
medium the free code camp medium blog
there was a posts about a week and a
half ago called putting comments into
code the good the bad and the ugly by a
certain bill server I'm sorry I said
that name wrong and basically details
how it's important to put comments into
code but you should do it in a way that
is helpful and there are things you
should and shouldn't do and so they
never really taught us that they just
said put comments in your code or else
we'll take marks off something like that
so building projects right so in a way
when you do your assignments it's kind
of like building a project but they
don't in the end it's still a class
assignment right you just want to get it
over with
and once once you've done it you just
kind of toss off into the side you know
you don't really want to look at it
anymore and so you're not really
encouraged to go back and improve on
your projects and you further not and
taking the next step and finally is
application of theory so if you go into
the data structures class I know you and
you'll ask them have you built a binary
tree data structure before they'll say
they'll probably say yes because that
was their last assignment in the class
and you know they have built it but if
you asked them you know when would you
use a binary tree to store data instead
of know an array a stack linked list
they they may not really be able to tell
you they may be able tell you some of
the advantages but not really how or in
what situation you would use them
so that was learning how to code and
another big thing was version control so
get in github is you know pretty
essential for working in groups and
collaborating with others and and just
for keeping track of your own work and
make sure you don't lose your progress
so they don't really teach this in any
any of the classes they I asked a friend
before who took the classes a few
semesters before he said that no they
didn't teach it but in my human-computer
interaction class the professor
attempted to explain to us how to use
git now as they attempted because I
don't think he's succeeded if you walked
into that class not knowing how to use
git you came out still not knowing how
to use git and you were probably even
more confused about what it was from
before so yeah I think that would that
would be a nice thing to learn you know
maybe freshman or sophomore year as
you're getting into working on your
projects and keeping track of your
progress and lastly you know relating to
version control and github you know
collaboration a lot of your assignments
you know they tell you to do it on your
own right and so that kind of
discourages you from copying from others
cheating although you know academic
integrity stuff like that but when you
do that you're kind of you don't really
get to experience working on a software
project as a team now when you just
think of work on group projects in
school in general is they okay you do
this I do that and we'll just put all
together when we're done and that
doesn't really work all the time with
software especially when you go into a
job and you have to work on the team and
the team you may not always get to meet
the team right they may be working
remotely things like that so learning
collaboration would have been a good
thing to know
I believe they teach I believe you have
a bit more group work later on the
degree in the last year of study but not
so much in the first three
now what that being said there were
things that that did help and I did find
useful and first thing was I got used to
coding right so when you do all your
assignments you know you do code you do
your assignments and so when you get to
the job it doesn't really feel all that
all that foreign and you know it
you get used to having you know other
students and your professors look at
your code and so compared to maybe
someone who is always learning on their
own didn't really get a chance to show
other people their code I kind of feel
like that helped me there
next thing was I now find learning a new
programming language not you know not
that bad I said you know most of my
classes were taught in Java
the data structures class was taught in
C++ and so the professor never really
went over much more than you know how to
assign variables how to know write a
function just basic syntax and all of
the all of the quirks of the language we
were left to you know figure out for
ourselves you know things like pointers
stuff like that and so the important
part was that you understood the
fundamentals of programming right like
in most languages you'll have a for loop
or a while loop or an if statements and
once you understand that all you really
need to do is go look up the syntax
rather than having to figure out how do
for loops work in this language because
they all work you know more or less the
same way
and finally how to search for help right
working on assignments really forces you
what I mean doesn't force you but I had
to Google for help a lot right had to go
on stackoverflow a lot and look up you
know variety of things and when I was at
my internship I don't think I mentioned
this earlier but I didn't study any HTML
before I went to the internship so web
dev wasn't even a thing that I'd
considered before that and so I had to
look up stuff know every day for the
first week or two when I was just
learning HTML on the fly and so I think
these are the three things that really
helped me while I was there
I think I've gone on long enough so just
to wrap up learning computer science
didn't really directly help me there
were things that kind of you know made
it easier but nothing directly helped
because you know I was working with HTML
and CSS maybe a little to JavaScript and
they didn't teach that at school I mean
why would they
so my name as the cheers don't worry if
you're not a computer science major or
if you you know stop studying CS it's
not a big deal
especially when you're working in
something like front-end web development
where it's more about the design and you
know building pages rather than worrying
about how to sort of sort an array
efficiently or how to balance a binary
tree you know and what's important
remember is just number fundamentals how
to write clean clean code how to use
version control how to collaborate with
others working on no big projects and
yep that's it for me and yep feel free
to contact me if I have any questions